drew brees joins us now is your jersey
retired at Purdue no I don't think we
got any I don't think we have any
jerseys is there there's probably a lot
that would go before me but yeah they we
don't we kinda leave it we kind of leave
it all open there Purdue well maybe you
haven't had you had Leroy keys I'm
trying to think you had uh Mike Phipps
like who were the great Bob Griese Bob
Griese all right you ready you ready for
that you ready for the cradle a
quarterback list at Purdue okay all
right so we got Linda awesome Hall of
Famer Bob Griese all the Famer Mike
Phipps these are all guys that had eight
plus your careers in the NFL as well
okay
beyond their college glory so mike says
gary Danielson yeah
Mork Herman yeah Scott Campbell yeah Jim
Everett and then other NFL guys after
that would be myself Kyle Orton Curtis
Painter so we got it we have about eight
to ten NFL quarterbacks with eight plus
years when's the last time you went back
to Purdue I was there twice last year I
went back for homecoming it's honor Joe
tiller who passed away last fall and it
was a reunion for one of our Bowl teams
and then I went back for the opener
against Louisville last year as well if
not Purdue where would you have gone my
two offers were Purdue in Kentucky so I
went on went on visits throughout those
places and then I went on a visit to
Brown University to Ivy League they gave
that strong consideration but thumbs up
ended up at Purdue offense love the
academic reputation Purdue playing the
big time
those are the main factors well also you
were running an offense that was cool
before anybody else was running that
kind of offense right you guys were
doing spread stuff shotgun stop Joe
Taylor was a really bright offensive guy
now he was absolutely he he was he was
doing a lot of that stuff at Wyoming I
mean they were lighting it up up there
and so he gets the job at Purdue in
December of 1996 so basically the 1997
team would be his first recruiting class
and he was bringing in the spread on
offense to the Big Ten which was kind of
unheard of and it was kind of sunk but
at the time you know Big Ten had that
reputation of three yards in a cloud of
dust and you know no way you could bring
that type of offense in that they tend
to be successful but he obviously proved
a lot of people wrong took a team that
had had a winning season in ten years
and and I think we went nine and three
our first year there in 1997 and then
had bowl teams every year for about ten
years straight after that won the Big
Ten in 2000 went to the Rose Bowl that
year so yeah listen it was a lot of fun
there's a lot of fun playing against the
competition we were playing against
spread it out throwing it you know 4050
times a game that was a quarter of extra
if you went to brown they probably would
have retired new jersey there you know
it's funny I just I think I think just
if when people think about Purdue and
they think about football they don't
necessarily see Purdue is as having a
strong you know football reputation
maybe but when you really go and look at
the number of players that have come out
of Purdue had successful NFL careers you
you could you could you can make an
argument that it actually does have a
pretty strong football reputation and
there's definitely a number of guys that
probably deserve to have their jerseys
retired but I just don't think we've
ever taken that approach I don't think
the universities are taking that
approach we just you know obviously put
a put a high value on on student
athletes and the value of their
education and the value of their ass but
active athletic performance as well but
but don't you know don't make it all
about football or sports these drew
Brees the Saints open up their season
versus the Buccaneers
Sunday I got some stats here for you the
NFL let's say you have 12 straight four
thousand yard seasons only two players
in NFL history of thrown for at least
4,000 yards when starting the season at
age 39 or older one is obvious that's
Tom Brady last year the other one do you
know so what's that you said only nine
yards only two quarterbacks in NFL
history of thrown for 4,000 yards when
starting the season at the age of 39 or
older okay far yep Favre was 39 Brady
was 40 how do you explain Brady like
from one great quarterback to another
how do you explain that it's it's really
impressive yeah he obviously has a has a
pretty incredible regimen you know for
not just physically but mentally
emotionally you know psychologically
preparing himself every offseason and
then going into every season
it's listen it's tough you know but a
ton of respect to him and you know the
routine that he's put together to still
allow himself to play such a high level
but do you think as competitive as you
are if if you see these lists of the
best quarterback in the NFL is Tom Brady
then it'll be Aaron Rodgers and then
probably you at three the competitor in
you inside your head or your wife you're
talking like do you think you're better
than brie or do you think you're better
than Brady and Aaron Rodgers
I think listen I've got a ton of respect
for those guys I don't I don't I don't
look at it that way
you know I don't I don't sit around and
say that you know my goal in life is to
be better than Tom Brady or Aaron
Rodgers or my goal with this career you
know I think I'm very very focused on
just my team and what I need to do to
help my team win and understanding that
when it's all said and done you know
you'll be evaluated based upon a lot of
different things you know and is that
the most important thing to me no you
know I'm I'm just trying to enjoy the
moment as much as I can
understanding that you know I'm closer
to the end and I am the beginning of my
career and I just want to enjoy every
second of it and accomplish all that
there is to be accomplished you know in
this chapter in my life and then move on
to the next one and then we can reflect
you know when it's all said and done but
you know drawing those comparisons or
having you know people sit around and
compare you know who's better at this or
who's better at that that's not that's
not really what I think about because if
you ask me do I think I'm better than
and you started naming sportscasters
like I'm that competitive that I like I
wanted I would say yes in certain cases
I would say yes or in certain cases I
would say no but I mean your list is so
small of who is considered better than
you that you know being around you I
would just think you'd be like I hold my
own with though I'm as good as bribe
radio you know later I could do what
Brady does look at I like this though
would you look at other people in your
industry and and say you know I I
respect that about them I appreciate
that about them I admire that about them
or you know hey maybe there's something
that they're better at than I am and yet
maybe there's some things that I'm
better at than they are yes that makes
sense yes what are you better at than
Brady no I think my point is that
there's a very high level of
appreciation for what the what the
quarterback position does and so as I
sit there and I watch the tape every
week of my opponents and of other games
and other quarterbacks around the league
I'm constantly kind of making note you
know and
[Music]
and there's things when I look at when I
watch enter Rogers play and just say
it's the best I've ever seen right like
uh there are certain things that he does
that I have never been able to do nor
will ever be able to do right and so
there's a level of respect and
appreciation when it comes to that but
then I also recognize okay well if I if
I want to play though at the level that
competes with that then these are the
things that I can control you know these
are the things that I can be the best at
and so I'm going to focus on those
things what advice would you give the 22
year old version of you well here's the
thing I feel like the the best teacher
in life is is experienced and in many
cases its failure right and so I'd want
to I think on the surface you'd say well
I don't want to go back and tell myself
don't do that don't make that mistake
don't don't be an idiot you know and yet
having gone through those things has
made me the person that I am now and the
player that I am back I've that's I
gained the experience right and so you
know failure is a tough teacher it's
hard to have gone through that at time
you know the hardest thing is like to
watch your kids go through something and
I just struggle with stuff like you want
to just give them you want to give them
all the answers or make it easy for them
and yet you also understand that that's
not the best teacher right that's not
how they learn just like that's not how
you learned or made it part of who you
are so I wouldn't send something I
wouldn't change anything I was looking
at the schedule Khalil Mack being traded
to the Bears you don't run into the
Bears so good for you yeah obviously I
was there's always interesting moves
that are made you know here before the
seasons as cuts are being made and
there's you know those those big
decisions are
kind of being made so yeah we'll see how
that all plays out but that was
interesting but I think your coach
didn't you guys have a package just for
Khalil Mack when you played against him
I think Sean was talking about this do
you remember that uh last time you
played yeah yeah I remember it very well
there's so many leap pass rushers in
this league you know and there's a lot
of them and you gotta have you gotta
have plans for guys that you know are
game changers you know the guys that can
literally change a game in one play you
know you just don't don't want to be in
a position where those guys are beating
you who is the pass rusher that you can
hear coming well you sent all of them
you know I mean you're obviously young
see wired and programmed as a
quarterback to to try to have that
awareness but but you know again it's
just you know that you know the teams
that you're going up against that you
know you know where the the dangerous
the dangerous spots are and whether it's
a certain scheme or a certain pass
rusher in particular and man you just
gotta have a plan for those things it's
good to catch up with you are the boys
behaving for the most part they're doing
what nine years seven year old and six
year old boys do which is drive their
parents crazy for the most part but no
listener the the greatest thing in the
world I think is heaven like I know for
me growing up having a younger brother
you know just because you you know
you're the best of friends you're the
worst of enemies you know you're just
constantly battling it's highly
competitive at all times you know you're
always you know but but when it comes
down to it man you love each other so
much and so to watch them fight to watch
him fight and then all of a sudden to
have those moments where you know
they're just there for each other and
they got each other's back and you know
encouraging each other and helping each
other learn different that means just
that's that's the best best thing as a
parent to be able to sit back and watch
your kids interact like that and they
ever injured you
that injured me yeah uh uh well I just
know that if I'm ever in a position
where one of them to jump on my back
like they're gonna do it you know so
it's like if I go down to tie my
daughter's shoe or something like that
like I'm gonna like head on a swivel one
of them is you know drop an elbow on the
back of dad's neck or something like
that so okay that's how I take stay
young you know that's how you stay alert
you need to wear a red jersey around the
house so they don't hit the quarterback
seriously good to catch up with you good
luck against the Bucs thank you drew
drew brees joining us yeah there was a
little boys got if the Pro Bowl was the
funniest thing he's being interviewed
and they are just acting like little
boys throwing each other around throwing
each other onto the field it was just
great and Andrew got yelled at by his
wife like you know the what are you
doing like she's watching I think from
the Stanley you know you can't have the
kids they're running around roughhousing
throwing each other on the field like
yeah why not
god I love that those little guys four
more Dan Patrick show to the audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV or download the
Dan Patrick show at
[Music]